make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with the
conclusion of Batman's Superman number
five and for those guys who have been
following along with this you guys are
aware that what's been going on here is
the Batman who last kind of had this
grand plan right that's good that's
great big huge grand scheme and the idea
is that it were originated really
arriving on earth during the events of
the Dark Knights metal storyline now
some people had asked and I'd say this
in the comments some people had thought
the Batman who laughs had been killed
during the events of Dark Knights metal
and the reality is that he hadn't right
the Batman who last actually just kind
of skirted around a little bit he was
part of the of the immortal men I think
it was for a little while although
nothing really significant was done with
him I think he does kind of appear like
once in the first issue it wasn't really
until we got to the Batman story you
know that we basically saw you know this
whole depiction of the Batman who last
planned but the idea is that this plan
has really been going on for quite some
time and so the indication here is that
the actions of Barbados and all those
guys during Dark Knight's medal what's
really more of something they were doing
and the Batman who last was forming his
own scheme along the way but what he had
done at least what we knew about him is
that in his own universe when he had
destroyed all the various superheroes
including the Justice League and
Superman and so on and so forth that
what he had intended to do was to
basically repurpose the the watchtower
that the Justice League Watchtower in
his own universe so that he could
basically spread his influence
throughout any world that he arrives in
and that's what he's been doing here
right the whole idea was to basically
create a circumstance whereby the entire
Kryptonian system can be manipulated by
Jaime Reyes due to his abilities happen
to technology and then with the other
members of the infected with Jim Gordon
and those various characters they could
essentially open a portal to the Dark
multiverse or to the universe of the
Batman who lost and then bring the
Justice League Watchtower through and
infect the entire earth in one fell
swoop that's really what he's been
shooting to do the entire time and at
the end of the last issue they succeeded
in pulling the watchtower through now
remember the Batman who lost is
currently held in prison below the Hall
of Justice and he's been there since the
Batman story right even when this story
first picked up he's been there the
entire time but one of the things that
goes on is that the infection that he's
basically spread to Supergirl to Donna
Troy to Hawkman of these various
characters is that it allows him to
communicate with them on a frequency
that only they can hear presumably this
was developed by the Batman who last in
order to ensure the Superman couldn't
overhear but it's kind of funny here
because when this goes down Batman is
Superman still play their roles and in
fact Wilson does a really good job of
explain to us why it is they do what
they do and how they're functioning this
way but what they end up doing is
Superman initially tries to talk them
down now
the reality of this is that on the
surface they seem too far gone where
they seem too far to be able to talk
back into reason that's just not really
the case anymore instead it's just kind
of like these guys are screwed and like
there's no way to get them back this
kind of the indication that's put on
here but the reality is that where some
of the of the the bugs and the various
organisms that exist inside Superman's
Fortress of Solitude are basically
brought into this location at the end of
the day they're able to kind of offer
some measure of resistance but the main
focus is the watchtower itself now of
course Superman ends up traveling to the
watchtower and Batman's basically facing
off against a couple forces along the
way the problem with this and this is
where things really get hairy is that
when Superman actually enters the
watchtower then he sees the full gravity
of what's going on the fact that the
entire Justice League from the Batman
who lasts universe has been killed and
then he turns around and of course he
sees the bodies of himself as well as
Lois Lane and Jonathan Kent now this is
where things get really screwed up right
because if you guys recall during the
origin story of the Batman who last one
of the things that he had done is where
the Joker had died and ultimately Bruce
Wayne ingested the you know this super
potent toxin that turned him into the
Batman who last that when he had
basically traveled and kind of brought
Superman in tricked him into being their
dad Superman and Jonathan were exposed
to black kryptonite which basically
twisted them up screwed them up and they
ended up to being the ones to kill Lois
Lane presumably beating her to death
and then they themselves seemed to kid
succumb to kryptonite now I don't think
it's explicitly stated that they ended
up dying from black kryptonite exposure
but at this point I don't know what else
would have killed them and so as a
result of that it's really cool because
then Shazam and Supergirl show up on the
scene and you get to see something that
you don't really get to see all that
often where Shazam sort of taught
Superman you know it says all yeah man
it was bad that happened but you know I
guess you were just too weak in your
universe and kind of given a hard time
making fun of initially you know calling
him pathetic and and so on and so forth
and even where Supergirl joins in it
says yeah like I'm sorry about your loss
you know even if it is your family from
another world but this basically just
shows how outmatched you are that you
would be happier if you joined us
different things like that
Superman flip set he absolutely lashes
out and again you don't get to see that
that you don't get to see this very
often but it is cool to see when it does
happen because Supergirl is totally
taken by surprise she's like holy crap I
don't even know this was coming now this
is one of those things that fans really
point to when they talk about the
strength differences between Superman
and Supergirl because traditionally you
know like one of the
we mentioned in the previous video is
that historically supergirls always been
shown to be stronger and more powerful
than Superman but a lot of you guys also
made a really really good point when
what you said was that oftentimes at the
same time two kind of a company that
Supergirl is usually shown to be more
reckless and so because of that she
doesn't really hold back in the same way
Superman does and so the indication of
the Superman could actually be you know
and it seems to be possibly more
powerful than Supergirl he just holds
back his strength a lot more and it kind
of makes sense right you know Lex Luthor
or Superman get into a knock-down
drag-out fight and he just punches Lex
Luthor with all his strength or he's
gonna punch him into oblivion falcon
punch that's basically what it's gonna
end up turning into you know just
punching the absolute hell out of him
and so because that sue man usually
holds back but in this instance he
doesn't really have to because both
Supergirl and Shazam can take it the
other part of this is very quick
thinking on his behalf right Shazam
trying to call down his thunder two men
stepping out of the way it all Tamilians
up hitting Supergirl
it's cool to see these small little
moments go down but Superman is highly
pissed off and because of that is one of
these things where he's at a precipice
where he could snap and that's really
what the Batman who laughs has been
looking for to push Superman to a
position where he can snap right where
he can break because if he can break
that he could be recreated right he can
be put back together in a different way
presumably falling down that that darker
path now for Batman himself facing off
against Jaime Reyes of course it's
Batman right so he's always quick
thinking on the spot and so what he does
is he looks at hi me and he says
technically your scarab can't really be
infected but you can which means if
you're infected your scarabs not so
literally reaching into Jaime getting
the Scarab off and putting it on himself
basically he has all the powers of the
Blue Beetle now but it does allow him to
basically take back control of the of
the fortress of solitude which Jaime
Reyes has been controlling this entire
time
and so from there he ends up basically
temporarily knocking out Commissioner
Gordon and then starts talking to
Superman and this is where Williamson
basically makes this really really good
point in terms of why they don't fall
down the path of becoming bad guys
because Batman starts to basically speak
with Superman and saying look I get that
you're angry and so as a result of that
madman kind of talks him down this is
look you've got a chill you've got to
relax if we end up becoming like the
villains that we're facing will be
better villains than they ever worked
the other part of this and the reason
why these stories work so well is
because Batman basically makes this
statement right Superman always told
that man that you always worry too much
for the response of Batman is I never
really worried like I've never really
worried about things because I trust you
and that's a fear
important thing right because what it
shows is that Batman recognizes the
strength of Superman not insofar this
Superman can punch really hard and fly
fast those are things that that Batman
of course recognizes what is the
strength of Superman's character is the
fact that Superman is not so easily
corrupted and again with the Batman who
laughs universe is only the Batman who
laughs basically talks Superman into
killing his family and he was just
easily manipulated they literally had to
use kryptonite in order to turn Superman
in that way right so Superman's almost
as incorruptible thing that's the whole
entire nature behind doomsday clock
right Superman is incorruptible he can't
be screwed up that way and just as kind
of flies in the face of that but some
justice it's different you know it's
different it's not the same thing and so
as a result that of course the the
watchtower of the Batman who lost is
basically pushed into the Sun and
destroyed and then in turn the response
of Batman and Superman is to talk to
Commissioner Gordon and that's the
important thing to bear in mind here is
that when Batman was talking to Superman
and essentially talking him down what he
told him is you have to let Supergirl in
Shazam go because you chasing after them
is a distraction that's basically what
that is don't let them distract you in
that way let them go off and do their
thing we have to destroy this watchtower
but when they're talking to Commissioner
Gordon is basically saying hey look
there's a way to bring you guys back
we'll figure out what it is we'll turn
everybody back to the way they were so
if you really believe this is a
permanent thing and you somehow
officially one then please understand
that's not the case and that's what he
chimes in and says but where do you
think your friends are going though and
of course we end up realizing that in
reality the Batman who lost kind of saw
this coming now again that's where
things sort of wear thin and that's why
I say the nature of Batman really kind
of wears thin right because if you take
everything that Batman does and you
apply it to a different character then
suddenly you start to realize how
redundant Batman is and it's one of
these things works like well the Batman
who lasts always saw this coming he had
this all planned out the entire time and
so because of that he was able to
overcome whatever plan Batman had is one
of those funny things you know Batman
does the exact same thing he's written
the exact same way Batman is always like
he always comes out on top and that
you're basically seeing that nature of
Batman thrown onto a different character
so I would submit if what's going on
with the Batman who laughs really kind
of bores you imagine what it's like
reading Batman all the time it's pretty
much the exact same thing the difference
is that his tore his stories are just
told differently but it's kind of it's
kind of cool here because when they get
down there of course what the end of
realizing is they were played the entire
time this entire scheme was never
expected to succeed the scheme had like
the satellite being pulled through and
all the kind of stuff there was no
expectation it was actually
going to work right because if it was
why leave it to some group like the
secret six which could easily and most
likely be overtaken by Batman and
Superman so the whole purpose behind
what it was about and who laughed wanted
to do it was essentially instigate this
entire circumstance where it looked like
things were going to pop off Batman to
Superman we're going to respond they
were gonna get into a great big huge
fight and knowing how things were going
to go down they were going to have to
basically let some of the members escape
and do whatever it is they were going to
do in order to stop the watchtower from
basically transforming the entire world
into a world of people who laugh and so
in doing that it left the door open for
Shazam and Supergirl to take off and to
basically free the Batman who lost and
so now he's kind of out of his cell and
back into things again so what this does
is it basically you know really forces
Batman as Superman to come to the
realization that keeping everything that
was going on to themselves and certainly
not bringing in Wonder Woman who's part
of the Trinity was the wrong mistake to
make and of course she's gonna be pissed
but everything else that goes on with
the Batman who lost is actually followed
in in the Batman who lasts and the
infected you're the villain he'll arisen
right so it follows their own individual
escapades over there in my mind the
story's cool but the whole concept of
the Batman who laughs is kind of
starting to wear thin and it's really
just kind of this same thing all the
time right like you know there's a
circumstance that unfolds and somehow
the Batman who laughs was all worried he
was always able to prepare for a
circumstance but he didn't know what's
coming right it's like Batman you know
that prepares for things even if he
doesn't know what's going to happen
right so keep up hair is fur for unknown
factors which seem impossible but when
you're Batman or the Batman who laughs
you have the power of plot armor with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob quark you guys want to see my
uncensored videos my vs. videos and all
my early access videos make sure you
guys go over to patreon calm calm let's
explain and if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace we've got
some new patrons in our top tears over
on patreon.com slash comments explained
I want to give a shout out to Jason see
Austin s Jason s Austin H Phillip and
Austin B as well as Steven Z Eagle F
Joey M and Jeff are as well as Genesis
916 as always we just usually keep the
last name to it initial it helps you
guys to maintain your anonymity some of
you guys are expressed concerned about
having like your first and last name
thrown out there for the world to see I
do not blame you for you
guys who have joined up as part of our
patreon tiers that are eligible for Rob
Court honor guard rings those whose
rings have been sent out you should
already have them if you're a new person
who just joined up and you've been part
of this tier for a month your ring will
be mailed out to you so I want to say
thank you guys for being patrons
[Music]